we're in the middle of the day the Sun  beatin down warms things up the blood  right there ston and dripping already I  left this caribou out for several days  in the Sun it could warm up enough that  the meat would be thawing out and  eventually it would actually spoil even  though it's winter time so I got to get  this into the snow bury it to protect  you from the Sun and keep it frozen  these piles of snow have caribou  wandering the other for caribou I killed  are buried around here and I'm going to  bury this one  yeah got my caribou buried this snow  protected from the Sun it'll hide it  from Ravens flying over and I can keep  an eye on it right from my window  there's no way that something's going to  come out here and get it without me  seeing what's going on so I'm pretty  happy with this I can keep my caribou  right here until I'm ready to bring it  inside thaw it out cut it up and eat it